west orange dans le new-jersey c'est un
pas celui en bleu c'est mon père avec
son meilleur ami terry les inséparables
je reviens pas que tu es fort soit sa
teneur
j'ai grandi ici entre deux familles on
peut s'estimer vraiment heureux au clan
wallin et postroff qui aurait cru que
nos familles seraient aussi soudé
je débarque pour thanksgiving mais par
un soûlard sont pas là on pourrait dire
que la vie à orange est sans surprise au
moins ça là ce que tu es jolie maman la
chouape
et ça jusqu'au jour où ce qui arriva
au 4ème envie de vomir
tu viens d'avoir 24 carats delà pour
l'otan qui a déjà créé de sérieux
problèmes et arrête de lever les yeux au
ciel quand ce n'est pas ça ne fait pas
du tout quand tu veux jouer les pères
super sévère en direct qui simule mon
père ne simule pas dessiner le quatuor a
griffé quelque chose je me suis fait mal
à la cheville est ce qu'on ne peut pas
être normal et ce qui ne marche pas mon
jour je savais toi et moi on va aller
baiser l'attitude assez bien trouver le
coup de coeur de l'homme
or regarde-toi commence à spéculer pas
d'une maman et papa s'était séparé je
mettais une petite sortie g prend du bon
temps
une fois
on
comment
la vie
vous vous sentez